this year has been pretty weird for the
mac lineup because many of the macs we
were originally expecting to get haven't
showed up at all and are reportedly
being delayed with sources like ming chi
quo saying that we shouldn't expect the
mac pro the imac pro and even the mac
mini to get updated until next year and
out of nowhere apple gave us the max
studio which was almost a complete
surprise since we were expecting to get
the new high-end mac mini and that's
exactly what this video is going to be
about because we recently got some
bombshell leaks regarding proof that a
new mac mini has likely already been
created by apple and is waiting for
release but before i get into that major
leak i've got to go through all of the
previous pieces of evidence for why a
new mac mini should be coming soon first
of all the mac mini is now the only mac
for sale other than the mac pro that
still comes with an intel chip now
that's a problem because apple gave us a
two-year timeline for the transition to
their own apple silicon chips which
means that basically every intel mac
should be getting an apple silicon
replacement and according to mark german
who is by far the most reliable apple
analyst and leaker the two-year timeline
should be completed by apple's wwdc
keynote in june basically two years
after apple announced the transition now
that doesn't mean that the macs
necessarily have to be shipping by then
but they'll at least be announced by
june according to mark so what this
basically means is that apple either
needs to replace the intel mac mini with
a new apple silicon based model or they
can simply discontinue it just like they
did with the 27-inch imac and thankfully
we actually have some evidence for there
being a brand new mac mini out there
somewhere in the world right now but
let's go all the way back to the
beginning of the leaks for the new mac
mini to prove that we've been expecting
it for a while in the summer of last
year dylan dkt tweeted out that he was
expecting a new m1x mac mini to release
alongside the new macbook pros and even
before that john prosser released
renders of the leaked mac mini design
also mentioning that it could
potentially come as soon as the end of
the year but of course it got delayed
because apple wanted all of the
attention on the macbook pros instead on
top of that mark german has been
expecting a new mac mini ever since may
of last year with details pointing to it
coming with an m1 pro and m1 max chip
just like we got with the macbook pros
later that year he ended up mentioning
the high-end mac mini again in august
saying that it's coming in the next
several months and then in october right
after apple's macbook pro event he once
again confirmed that it should be coming
sometime in 2022.
he continued to mention it in december
and january reporting the apple is
likely to bring the m1 pro chip to
another mac in the first half of the
year which could be a higher end mac
mini or imac and then over the next
couple of months he made another three
reports concerning the mac mini even
going as far as to say that he's
expecting one high-end mac mini with an
m1 pro chip and one with an m2 chip
coming in the first half of 2022 but
then apple's march event came around and
while it seemed basically 100 likely
that apple was going to release a new m1
pro and m1 max high-end mac mini we of
course got the max studio instead which
was a huge surprise and since that
machine is basically a larger and more
expensive mac mini that starts with the
m1 max chip it could totally make sense
for apple to release a high-end mac mini
to replace the intel model but maybe
with just the m1 pro chip as the sole
option instead of the m1 max since
that's what the mac studio comes with
but moving on to the latest leaks that
came after the march event 95 mac had an
exclusive leak where they found internal
code referring to two new mac mini
models one being codenamed j473
which is the new m2 mac mini expected to
be announced sometime later this year
and then the j474
which is the m2 pro mac mini coming
later down the road possibly next year
and perhaps the most interesting part
was when 95 mac said that apple had
plans to introduce high-end versions of
the mac mini with the m1 pro and m1 max
chips but they were scrapped to make way
for the mac studio so what it makes it
seem like is that apple never even
planned to release the m1 pro mac mini
since they've been working on the mac
studio for a while which would mean that
we'd have to wait for the m2 mag mini to
come later this year but wait we've
actually got some new proof that the
high-end m1 pro and m1 max mac mini
actually does exist first of all if we
go back to may of 2021 when mark german
discussed a new more powerful mac mini
with the code name j374
the interesting part is that the new m2
and m2 pro mac minis that 95 mac leaked
have code names of j473
and j474 so j374 is still out there
somewhere and just in case you think
that the j374 mac mini turned out to be
the max studio the r evil quanta leak
found references to both j 374 and
j375 and 95 mac was able to confirm that
j375 is actually the code name for the
mac studio so with that said the j374
mac mini is still out there somewhere
and there's a chance that this could
actually be the high-end m1 pro mac mini
and finally with all of that out of the
way we just got a bombshell leak from
apple developer steve trouten smith he
was able to find a reference to a brand
new unreleased mac mini within the
studio displays firmware that it shipped
with titled the mac mini 10 comma 1
which means that apple could have been
originally planning to release the m1
pro mac mini alongside the studio
display but ended up releasing the max
studio instead now steve originally
guessed that it would be the m2 mac mini
but later the next day he revised his
guess and he now believes that the
unreleased mac mini is actually one that
comes with both the m1 pro and m1 max
chips and while it might seem weird to
have an m1 max option because that's the
chip the mac studio starts with steve
argues that it might be enough to push
people to bump up to the mac studio if
there's not a lot between them but i
personally think a model with just the
m1 pro chip makes sense because that'll
force you to pay more for the max studio
now with that said if steve is right and
we actually get an m1 pro mac mini later
this year this means that it could
technically be released at any time
since that ship has been around since
last year but wait the evidence gets
even better because way back in february
apple registered three new macs in the
eurasian database two desktop macs and
one laptop now one of those turned out
to be the mac studio and i personally
believe that the other registered
desktop mac model is the upcoming mac
mini and this leaves just one laptop
which i think has a chance to be the
redesigned macbook air because of some
recent major leaks and reports just days
ago mark grumman released his latest
power on newsletter where he mentioned
that apple is gearing up to launch some
new macs in the next few months and what
better place to do so than
wwdc specifically he said that there are
two new macs coming around the middle of
the year or early next year which
perfectly lines up with the two
unreleased macs that apple registered
with the eurasian database however for
the first time in months he completely
changed his predictions to say that one
of those is likely to be the new macbook
air with another model being potentially
an updated mac mini and the crazy thing
is that ming chaquel believes that the
2022 redesigned macbook air is coming as
soon as the end of the second quarter
which is in june with a new design more
color options and the m1 chip yes the
same m1 chip that we already have so if
this turns out to be true it would mean
that both the new m1 macbook air and the
m1 pro mac mini can technically be
released at any point because they're
using older chips that we already have
on other macs and this would mean that
apple can release these two macs in the
summertime just like mark german was
predicting and then they can wait until
the fall to release the new m2 chip
within the macbook pro and likely the
low end base m2 mac mini and this
actually makes sense because there have
been some reports pointing to the m2
chip arriving in the second half of 2022
including from the site commercial times
as well as mark german who believes the
m2 macbook pro will come by the end of
the year so with that said the m1 pro
mac mini and redesigned m1 macbook air
could end up coming sometime this summer
however
a couple of sources disagree with this
idea including 9 to 5 mac who believe
apple completely cancelled the m1 pro
mac mini in favor of simply releasing
the m2 mac mini this year and waiting
for the m2 pro version next year they
also believe that the redesigned macbook
air will in fact come with the m2 chip
instead of the m1 like ming chi quo
predicted and on top of that leek's
apple pro from eyedrop news believes
that apple is actually going to be
releasing two m2 macs at their wwdc
event with one of them for sure being a
mac mini and the other one potentially a
24 inch imac or a 13 inch base macbook
pro but either way whatever ends up
happening i think it's pretty clear that
we are in fact getting either an m1 pro
or m2 mac mini later this year
potentially as soon as wwdc in the
summer and i think that's some pretty
awesome news so hopefully you enjoyed
this video and if you did go ahead and
click the circle above to subscribe for
more videos like this one and be sure to
check out one of those two right over
there thanks for watching and we'll see
you in the next video
[Music]